[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing harry potter lord voldemort
and the very dangerous lie told by
narcissa malfoy there seems to be a
trend in the harry potter books and
films
with mothers protecting their children
lily with harry and her sacrificial
protection
molly with ginny and her impressive
defeat over bellatrix
and even narcissa malfoy who lied to
lord voldemort
after voldemort believes that harry has
been killed narcissa goes to check on
him
hence softer than he'd been expecting
touched harry's face
pulled back an eyelid crept beneath his
shirt down to his chest
and felt his heart he could hear the
woman's fast breathing
her long hair tickled his face he knew
that she could feel the steady pounding
of life against his ribs
is draco alive is he in the castle the
whisper was barely audible
her lips were an inch from his ear her
head bent so low that her long hair
shielded his face from the onlookers
yes he breathed back he felt the hand on
his chest contract
her nails pierced him then it was
withdrawn
she had sat up he is dead narcissa
malfoy called to the watchers
and now they shouted now they yelled in
triumph and stamped their feet
and through his eyelids harry saw bursts
of red and silver light shoot into the
air
in celebration still feigning death on
the ground
he understood now sister knew that the
only way she would be permitted to enter
hogwarts
and find her son was as part of the
conquering army
she no longer cared whether voldemort
won so clearly from what we've just read
we can see narcissa lying to voldemort
and the rest of the death eaters
while they are all of the impression
that harry is deceased narcissa is the
only one that actually knows that he is
alive
but why why would she risk lying to one
of the darkest wizards of all time
how did she even expect to be successful
legitimacy is the art of accessing
people's minds and reading their
thoughts
and voldemort is one of the most
impressive legitimates in the world
he mastered it during his time in school
and was actively determined to become
more skilled at it than any other witch
or wizard
with legitimacy voldemort could almost
always tell who was lying to him
and knew what you were thinking before
you uttered a word narcissa malfoy was
one of only two people
who were able to lie to voldemort
successfully the other being severus
snape
who was a highly accomplished oklahomans
so why would she lie
why take such a risk well once again
it comes down to motherly love she knew
that lying to voldemort would be the
only way that she would be able to
return to the castle
to search for draco she lied in order to
compel voldemort back to the castle
because she knew he wouldn't be able to
resist the opportunity to flaunt his
success
though narcissa was a devoted servant of
the dark lord her love for her family
would always come first
and lying to voldemort was a risk that
she was willing to take to protect her
son
draco had been used and abused by
voldemort and was given a nearly
suicidal role in the war as a way of
mocking the malfoy's
particularly lucius who'd let him down
it's likely that necessary resented
voldemort for that
when she found out that harry was still
alive she realized that there was a very
good chance
the good guys would prevail her
confidence in good prevailing over evil
had increased and she knew that lying
was the best chance that she would have
to see her son before he was potentially
killed for his affiliation with the dark
lord
jk rowling herself has actually
commented on this segment
explaining that this moment was designed
to emphasize the power of maternal love
love is so central to the harry potter
story and keeps returning throughout the
series
voldemort of course can't feel love
because of the way that he was conceived
because his mother and father didn't
genuinely love each other and because
his father was under the influence of a
love potion
he was born with an incapability of
feeling it while voldemort was left at
an orphanage with no real connection to
his biological mother
it's interesting that he should be
constantly bested by these maternal
connections
voldemort's biggest flaw as a person was
his inability to feel love
and time and time again it resulted in
his downfall
and that's it for this video as always
leave your video suggestions down in the
comment section below
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you